[Music]
we deep in the San Fernando Valley
suburban Los Angeles the kind of place
where you can raise a kid and not have
to worry about the scary in her City but
a little do people know that behind one
of these doors lies a house of
nightmares well it's really just
Guillermo del Toro's house he's got an
unbelievable collection of sci-fi horror
comic book just weird stuff
he calls it Bleak House let's check it
out
[Applause]
this guy greets everybody as they come
in our that's that's obviously Boris
Karloff if you are a real Franklin
technique I know this is the first movie
you can tell it because he has the
hollow on the right cheek which as a kid
you were wondering how did he do that
with makeup yeah what happened is Boris
removed his false teeth oh he had false
he has the whole right side was full
speed well let's let's start in here
what is this room this is horror we have
HP Lovecraft - yeah the famous famous
over there looking at HP Lovecraft is
ready Allan Poe Edgar Allan Poe yeah
with a hypodermic needle they put each
of the hairs of the sort of five o'clock
shadow and then they cut it unshaven so
you it - man yes yes it feels like
razors
yes how long did it take you before
having incredibly life-sized mannequins
freaked you out like you wake up in the
night Linda Blair watches TV with me in
the living room one of those little
Roomba vacuum cleaner and it activated
once and it said the motion control of
the alarm off and the Sheriff Department
came and so Linda Blair through the
window and they said there's a lady and
it's not moving and I have to prove that
first made of silicone this is very nice
this is a little miniature of the
Pirates of the Caribbean
captain Beth oh yeah I'm a complete
Disney freak I go to this one one two
three times a year at least do you hire
the personality it's um if I'm going
with a group I try I am in possession of
far too much shame to do that yeah just
be like you know oh look it's that guy
from TV's going
there's a few medical things in the
house and this is she's from freaks yeah
yeah this kook of the Gert the bird girl
yeah yeah over there is johniac a half
fun oh yeah from the movie freaks oh and
look at these are all Hellboy guns yeah
no yeah good home protection the only
hero gone wait for the movie baby we
used to put a line here to hold the gun
when he pointed out this song so happy a
big fire or a weakling Ron Perlman this
is the fantasy and children story
section no oh look at that every house
and its it's a hundred mansion room oh
it's a haunted mansion yeah I thought
this is just the murder suite ghost and
he became for aficionados he became the
the favorite ghost oh I see so I had him
reproduced life-sized because it seemed
like the reasonable thing to do
yeah yeah why not well I guess a the
kitchens kind of disappointing the
scariest thing are what is in the fridge
[Music]
let's see the pinhead from Mary phone
phreaks this would be a terrible house
to be drunk in just knowing priceless
artifacts the only the only thing I
drink is planned oh but this whole thing
is the vampire and werewolf room with
vampire which is estranged it's the
valley and this is Ray Harryhausen again
by Mike Hill Wow with the skeletons from
jason and the argonauts making him some
tea
well any Minchin see you have ours these
are old all the robots oh well sorry
about that
look I'm gonna now find that in my
friends is good well thank you so much
for the tour it's such a thrill to be
able to see it
that's right Linda's here so we're gonna
watch some TV but there what would you
like to see Linda an Antiques Roadshow
Yankee true about her
[Music]
[Applause]
you